foreign
Birmingham hey Brittany welcome to the
Ramsey Show
great how can we help
yeah so um I my question is kind of more
of a moral thing than a money thing
um so my husband is 25 and I'm 23.
they've been married for just over a
year and we've recently kind of decided
that we want to start seeing where every
penny of our money goes and both of our
parents love you we've grown up you know
going to your classes and reading your
books so we know everything
um and my mother-in-law decided that she
wanted to offer us some advice so we
started to take some of her advice and
then one day she came to us and said I
just want to go ahead and make your
budget for you and I immediately laughed
this off and I thought this is crazy
like I would not do that I think she's
joking but my husband thought that it
was a really good idea and I that's so
sweet
and I begged and pleaded with him to not
let her do this and so I finally got him
to agree for us to work on our budget
together alone and I thought it would be
for our eyes only but in the middle of
us writing down our paychecks like our
bills and things like that he called his
mom and asked her to come over and she
came over to our house and looked at
everything do you hear the helicopter
blades
foreign
yeah yeah and she she came over and she
looked at everything and I on the way
while she was on the way after eating up
I begged and pleaded with him to not let
her come over I cried I was like please
don't do this I wanted to do this
together and he told me that I was
acting like a child and that it was
ridiculous for me to be acting this way
and it was perfectly okay for his mom to
look at our budget who's the child I'm
like oh my God who's the child here he's
the mommy's Boy geez
exactly and I I said this and I told my
parents and my parents are Furious they
were like what is he thinking
um and basically
she came over and looked at everything
and he even let her take it home with
her and do it herself okay so Britney
right now you're 100 right
you're not crazy
you need to stop this from happening
this is a boundary violation helicopter
Mommy and Mommy's boy need to learn the
idea that the Bible says leave and
cleave you leave your parents and you
cleave to your spouse that includes you
too Brittany instead of calling your
parents yeah don't call your mommy and
daddy yeah y'all need a yep a marriage
counselor and duct tape so where do we
stand today
um so she took the budget home with her
and basically a few days later we both
got a text message and a group chat with
her she had written everything out that
we make and uh said this is what you say
from this paycheck and blah blah blah
and I texted her very nicely and said we
will decide what we do with our money
um and she didn't like that my husband
didn't like that he thought that I was
being rude to her I have suggested
marriage counseling I have suggested
going to counseling and he does not um
he does not believe in that he doesn't
think that that stuff works he refuses
to go so that's not really an option I
am just calling to get some advice to
see
um if I'm crazy for thinking that this
is completely wrong and
um my parents also agree with me they
think that it's absolutely insane and
um yeah so I'm just calling for advice
to see what you have to say so
when it comes to relationships Brittany
and money what we always find is usually
it has to do with there's the problems
and the issues going on within the
relationship
it's not about the budget it's about
that your husband didn't listen to you
your husband didn't respect your opinion
shoots you off like you were a child
and kept bulldozing his way through
right that that that to me yes your
mother-in-law doing the budget all that
that is that's an issue but for me as if
I were you sitting in your position
that's the issue that I that makes me my
feelings are hurt you know sure well
yeah you weren't listened to so uh but
let's let's make sure that you what
Rachel's saying you're getting this your
feelings don't need to be heard at your
mother-in-law they need to be heard it's
your husband yeah yes he's the problem
she's the symptom
that's right yeah
so so Brittany what I mean what I I if I
were you guys you've been married less
than right right at a year less than a
year
yes just over a year yep
um I would find people in his life that
you guys have a really great
relationship with and I don't know if
that's friends it doesn't need to be
family uh I don't know if that's friends
I don't know if there's like a mentor or
someone that he really looks up to but I
would I you need someone else speaking
into this versus us sitting here in
Nashville you know we can we can give
you our advice but really to have people
walk with you because he needs to get to
a point of humility uh to be able to to
to say that therapy is not wrong and I
know some people have like this weird
thing about it but to go to go to
marriage counseling uh but to hear other
people speak into his life because I'm
scared that it's like he's so tunnel
visioned into what he wants to do
including bringing his mom into those
situations that you that you're you're
not being heard within your marriage and
so and I want to make sure you're
communicating it well too right that
you're not you know yeah I don't think
you need to text her about this again I
think you need to bust him
yes and I've tried to have that
conversation no no no you just blew it
off
you're you're there is no excuse for you
to go after her again she's not the
problem
she's the symptom I want you to direct
all of your Force into your marriage
relationship
because that's where all of this is
I have an island met with you're acting
like a child you're being ridiculous
you're being rude yeah I heard you say
that but my point is that doesn't then
then you turn left and go text her
uh which kind of verified what he was
saying
and so instead of going at him
because
this guy's relationship with his mom is
about three notches too far over the
edge
okay period
period anybody listening is going this
is a problem he's a got a mama's boy
syndrome and uh everybody listening is
going yeah this is kind of obvious you
know everybody but him and his mom and
so the good news is this this young boy
has a chance to grow up and be a man now
and be a husband and uh he's got an
opportunity to step into manhood and the
part of that is uh loving and respecting
your mother as an adult at a bit of a
distance that's right and um with
reasonable boundaries and and listening
to your wife hello like yeah
that's my that's my problem run into
your mom and dad y'all are both acting
like your children okay you the two of
you need to take this inside of your
house inside your four walls and jump on
the fact that your relationship is
busted and his respect for you your
all's ability to communicate your
eligibility problem solved without
bringing in outside forces called
in-laws is limited and you need some new
tools to work on that so yeah do you
guys attend a good church by chance
um we don't at the moment I work on
Sundays
um and he works he's on call he's a
lineman so you don't have a good uh
uh pastor's connection that you could
use to just sit down with a pastor
okay that's fair all right then you do
just need to get a hold of a good
marriage counselor or call a good local
Pastor there in Birmingham and just see
if they'll meet with you but um uh you
know no uh you are not being childish
you know you're not being unreasonable
to not want her in there possibly some
of your reactions to the whole situation
once you've lost it we're a childish I
don't know about that but um you know
this is a relationship question it is
not a budget question this is a boundary
violation if Sharon Ramsey inserted
herself into Rachel and Winston's uh so
Daniel wants to be her son that'd be the
same thing yeah in the Daniel's
situation uh Daniel would not allow that
Allison would not allow that
um and I would not allow her to do that
um so I mean there'd be a lot of not
allowing here it's called Boundaries yes
um but for young let's go on I'm the I'm
the guy that teaches America how to do a
budget by the way and I haven't ever
done a budget for any of my grown
married children ever and I remember
coming up today the house once and I
were probably married about two years
and there was a money thing I can't
remember what it was it was like we had
we had some money and it was like should
we invest it here should we say put it
in a meet like we were it was a pretty
basic question
and you wouldn't answer it you're like
what do you guys think what do you think
what do you think what do you think I'm
like I don't know what to think that's
why I'm asking you should have called
into the show Rachel I should have gone
into the show I would have gotten the
answer I know but but for real though
there's a there's a balance in
overbearing but then young couples
listening to have wisdom speak into your
life yeah she apparently is good at
doing a budget it would have been nice
to have her input so she wasn't
controlling exactly but you can't ask
this woman for anything because she
doesn't know when to stop I know she's
like that Bulldog I had it but never win
this knew when to stop eating so I'd get
fat okay so just cut the food off I'm
thinking about all the young couples
though listening and they've been
married for a year you're you know year
and a half and they don't know maybe
they have questions about their money
and maybe their parents are really great
at money how what what is the
appropriate I think you can ask for help
with that uh and ask for input on
anything those are good if you're both
good with that number one but number two
if the person you're asked asking
has reasonable boundaries
and is not going to artificially insert
themselves over the line into the
situation okay now one of the reasons
you got the answer you and Winston got
was uh you're asking me but also you're
asking me in the sense that you you
understand your husband has married into
this family at that time this is what's
going through my head when you're asking
me this question that is uh bigger than
life that takes up all the air in the
room and that everywhere we go it's all
about Dave and it'd be nice for
something to be about Winston and so I'm
like no I'm not getting in this
if it had been a normal situation I
would have answered the question as your
dad but because we're not normal we're
weird you know I Gotta Give I got to
give Winston some space and that's why I
pushed back on y'all I'm like y'all go
figure it out you kind of know the
answer and he already knew the answer
probably but I didn't want him thinking
that he was in my shadow he's the
son-in-law right right you know and
because I got a big old Shadow you know
and so I got to be careful with that